WELCOME BACK, HUGE CROWDS OF
MIGRANTS AT THE, BORDER BETWEEN
BELARUS, AND POLAND, GONE, NOW
MOVED TO A GIANT WAREHOUSE
NEARBY.
BUT, THE CRISIS, FAR FROM OVER.
BELARUS, FLYING HUNDREDS OF
PEOPLE BACK TO IRAQ, BUT OTHER
MARGARINES, STILL, HOPING FOR
REFUGE IN GERMANY.
WITH LEADERS BLAMING BELARUS
FOR ORCHESTRATING THE CRISIS,
IN RETALIATION, FOR SANCTIONS
PUT ON THE LUKASHENKO
GOVERNMENT.
THE BELARUSIAN FOREIGN MINISTER,
HE SAYS THAT IS A LIE.
HE, SPOKE EXCLUSIVELY, WITH
CNN'S MATTHEW CHANCE.
>> AT THE AIRPORT, IN MINSK,
THE FIRST REPATRIATION FLIGHT
WAITS TO BOARD.
THE PASSENGERS, MOSTLY, IRAQI
KURDS, DID NOT MAKE IT TO
EUROPE.
BUT AT LEAST, THEIR BELL ROOFS
ORDEAL IS AT AN END.
THIS IS THE NIGHTMARE THEY LEFT
BEHIND.
OFFICIALS CONFIRMED, THIS
FOREST CAMP, ON THE POLISH
BORDER, NOW, IS EMPTY.
THE SHOCKING IMAGES OF
DESPERATE MIGRANTS, LANGUISHING
IN THE COLD, HAVE LEFT A MARK.
NOW, FOR THE FIRST TIME, CNN IS
ABLE TO HOLD A SENIOR,
BELARUSIAN OFFICIAL, TO
ACCOUNT.
>> TO SEE HOW THEY SUFFER, IT'S
VERY DIFFICULT FOR A NORMAL
HUMAN BEING.
WE ARE NOT INTERESTED IN HAVING
THE SITUATION, HERE, AND
DOLORES.
>> YOU SAY YOU DON'T WANT TO
SEE THE SCENES, BUT YOU ARE
ACCUSED, OR BELARUS IS ACCUSED,
OF ORCHESTRATING THIS ENTIRE
CRISIS.
OF ENCOURAGING MIGRANTS TO COME
HERE, AND OF DIRECTING THEM
TOWARDS THAT BORDER.
YOU CREATED THE SCENES.
>> YES, WE HAVE HAD A LOT OF
ACCUSATIONS TOWARDS BELARUS.
THIS IS A FALSE ASSESSMENT.
>> ALSO FALSE, ACCORDING TO THE
FOREIGN MINISTER, U.S., AND
EUROPEAN ALLEGATIONS, THAT
RUSSIA, WHICH RECENTLY FLEW THE
STRATEGIC BOMBER FLIGHTS, OVER
BELARUS, AND SUPPORT, REALLY,
IS BEHIND THE CRISIS,
ENCOURAGING ITS ALLY TO
DISTRACT THE WEST.
WHILE PREPARING MILITARY PLANS
ELSEWHERE IN UKRAINE.
>> AS WE GOT TO THIS MIGRANT
CRISIS, I CAN, DEFINITELY, SAY
THAT RUSSIA HAS NOTHING TO DO
WITH IT.
>> BUT, IT WAS PRESIDENT PUTIN,
HE TELLS, ME WHO SORT OF
TELEPHONE CALLS BETWEEN THE
GERMAN, AND BELARUSIAN LEADERS,
THIS WEEK.
HOPING TO DEFUSE THE CRISIS.
>> AND, IT NEEDED TO FUSING.
THIS IS THE SCENE WHEN ANGRY
MIGRANTS TRIED TO FORCE THEIR
WAY INTO EUROPE, PAST POLISH
BORDER GUARDS.
THE REFUSAL OF BELARUS TO
INTERVENE, FUELING RUMORS THAT
THEY ENCOURAGED THESE ATTACKS.
>> THE EUROPEAN UNION SAYS,
BELARUS HAS CREATED THIS CRISIS,
TO PUNISH THEM, IN REVENGE FOR
THE SANCTIONS THAT THE EU HAS
IMPOSED AGAINST BELARUS, FOR
ITS CRACKDOWN ON THE
OPPOSITION.
HOW DO YOU ANSWER THAT
ALLEGATION?
THERE >> IT IS A LIE.
IT'S AN ABSOLUTE LIE.
BELARUS HAS SHOWN THAT THAT
SIDE OF THE EUROPEAN DEMOCRACY.
AND, YOU HAVE SEEN, YOURSELF,
WHAT WAS HAPPENING, AT THE
BORDER WITHIN THE LAST 2, OR 3,
DAYS.
>> IT HAS SHOWN THE STRENGTH OF
EUROPEAN UNITY, TO.
THE NOW REMAINING MIGRANTS, IN
BELARUS, ARE BEING HOUSED IN
THIS GIANT, HEATED WAREHOUSE.
BACK FROM THE VOLATILE BORDER.
BUT, WITH EUROPE, REFUSING TO
BACK DOWN, IT IS BELARUS THAT
MUST, NOW, KEEP THEM, OR SOME
THEM HOME.
MATTHEW CHANCE, CNN, MINSK.
CNN INTERNATIONAL DIPLOMATIC
EDITOR, NIC ROBINSON, JOINS, ME
LIVE, IN LONDON.
REPATRIATION TO IRAQ UNDERWAY,
GERMANY SAYS IT WON'T BE
BULLIED INTO TAKING THOSE WHO
REMAIN IN BELARUS.
WHAT HAPPENS TO THEM?
WHAT IS NEXT ON ALL OF THIS?
>> I THINK IT'S ONE PART OF AN
ONGOING SAGA, BETWEEN
BELARUSSIA, AND THE EUROPEAN
UNION.
WHAT HAPPENED TO THOSE MIGRANTS,
CAUGHT UP IN THIS MOMENT, THE
INDICATIONS ARE, A, ROCK AT,
LEAST IS OFFERING TO TAKE BACK
ALL OF THOSE WHO WANT TO COME
BACK.
THE POLISH PRIME MINISTER SPOKE
WITH THE IRAQI PRIME MINISTER,
AND VOWED, HE WOULD DO
EVERYTHING HE COULD TO HELP
THOSE PEOPLE GET BACK, WHO WANT
TO GET BACK.
BUT, INEVITABLY, THERE WILL BE
PEOPLE WHO WANT TO STAY, AND IT
IS SOMETHING TO COME BACK TO.
IT IS SOMETHING SPENT WITH
THEIR LAST REMAINING MONEY TO
GET BACK TO BELARUSSIA, BECAUSE
IT IS SO CLOSE TO EUROPE.
THEREFORE, THEY WERE NOT
PREPARED TO GIVE UP.
AT THE MOMENT, IT SEEMS THAT
IT'S THEIR RESPONSIBILITY FOR
THEM, AND HOW TO MANAGE IT, AND
WILL LAND WITH THE GOVERNMENT
IN MINSK, WITH ALEXANDER
LUKASHENKO.
I THINK THE INDICATIONS ARE
TOUTED BY THE BELARUSIAN SIDE,
AND THE IDEA THAT GERMANY WOULD
TAKE SO MANY THOUSAND, AND
BELARUSSIA WOULD SEND THE
OTHERS BACK.
WHAT AWAITS THEM IS A, VERY,
VERY, DIFFICULT SITUATION.
AND, POTENTIALLY, BEING TOLD
THAT YOU MUST LEAVE.
IT IS UP IN THE AIR AT THE
MOMENT.
>> I'M CURIOUS, HAS THIS
EXPOSED FAILING, IN THE EU'S
OWN MIGRANT POLICIES, PUSHING
MIGRANTS BACK?
THAT, FOR EXAMPLE, IS BEING
CRITICIZED TO CONTRARY TO
HUMANITARIAN NORMS.
IT IS BEING EXPOSED IN SOME
WAYS.
>> THERE ARE ARGUMENTS FOR THE
EUROPEAN UNION, WITH THE
EFFORTS OF LUKASHENKO, AND THEY
DON'T FOLLOW DEMOCRATIC
POLICIES WHO, HAD AN ELECTION,
LAST YEAR, BY ALL ACCOUNTS, ONE
AT FRAUDULENTLY, ALTHOUGH HE
WOULD DENY IT.
IT DID NOT RECOGNIZE AS A
LEGITIMATE PRESIDENT WITH THE
EUROPEAN UNION.
IT WAS, AS THE EUROPEANS SAY,
IT IS MANIPULATION.
IT WAS AN ABNORMAL SITUATION,
AND YOU HAVE AN AUTOCRAT WHO
HAS A GOOD VALUES OF
DEMOCRACIES, WHICH IS HELPING
PEOPLE, AND TRYING TO SHOW, IN
FACT, WHAT HAPPENED, IS THAT
THE EUROPEAN UNION ISN'T
HOLDING UP ITS OWN VALUES.
I THINK YOU HEARD IT WITH THEIR,
AND WITH THE FOREIGN MINISTER
SAID AS WELL.
SO, THIS IS A POSITION THAT,
DEMOCRACIES, AROUND THE WORLD,
FIND THEMSELVES THEM.
UNDER PRESSURE FROM
AUTOCRACIES.
THOSE POLITICAL GAIN, AT HOME,
FOR LUKASHENKO.
IF HE CAN PULL OFF THIS
MANIPULATION OF THE SITUATION,
THAT IS HAPPENING.
BUT, FUNDAMENTALLY, WITH THE
EUROPEAN UNION, POLITICAL
LEADERS ARE SAYING, SIMPLY, IS
THAT THIS IS NOT A NORMAL
SITUATION.
THESE ARE NOT NORMAL MIGRANTS,
WHO HAPPEN TO HAVE ARRIVED AT
THE BORDER, AND ARE STILL
TRYING TO CLAIM POLITICAL
ASYLUM.
THIS HAS BEEN A MANIPULATION,
FROM ALLOWING SO MANY MIGRANTS
TO GET VISAS, TO GET INTO
BELARUSSIA.
AND THEN, HELPING THEM GET TO
THE BORDER.
FUELING THE NOTION, THEY MAY BE
ABLE TO CROSS THE BORDER.
HELPING THEM OUT, TO A DEGREE.
GIVEN THESE MIGRANTS, AND
PERMISSION TO DO THINGS, AND
WITH THE RUSSIAN CITIZENS,
BELARUSIAN CITIZENS, DON'T
HAVE.
THAT IS A FRUSTRATION NEAR
OPINION HAS.
FOR THAT REASON, THEY SAY, THIS
IS NOT A NORMAL SITUATION.
THAT PUTS THEM IN THIS POSITION
OF HAVING AN AUTOCRATIC TO